You can send just about anything by air these
days, from letters to spacecraft.
Which means cargo planes have to come in lots
of shapes and sizes… but what’s the real
difference here?
It’s you.
So let’s start with what we know: a commercial
passenger flight.
And to be honest, you all are heavy.
Depending on the plane, a passenger flight
can have anywhere between 150 and 400 people
who weigh a lot; the average American woman
weighs 169 pounds (77kg) while the average
man weighs 196 pounds (89kg).
Take out the people and that plane is a lot
lighter.
3With no people or their luggage or little
dogs or babies, and there’s no need for
seats!
Seats are getting lighter with new materials
like polyester mesh.
And newly designed features mean seats made
of titanium can weigh less than 10 pounds
(4.5kg), But still, lose those too.
So no people and no seats means no one to
look out the windows, so they’re also unnecessary
on cargo planes.
Taking out the windows lowers the overall
mass, making the plane more fuel efficient.
And that’s the goal when carrying cargo.
Replacing windows with aluminum panels or
another kind of window plug can make things
way lighter, but even better is never having
had windows at all.
There’s no support structure to deal with
around the hole in the plane, and there’s
less drag on the smoother fuselage.
Since you aren’t walking around the plane
we can change out the floor and lose the carpet
too.
Freight aircraft have floors that promote
easy onloading and offloading of cargo palettes,
often with ball bearings or rollers.
Converting a plane from a passenger jet to
a cargo plane by taking out all these things
is far cheaper than buying a new plane, so
that’s why you see freight planes with window
outlines and other features that look like
passenger planes.
Though it’s not the case that a plane carries
either passengers or cargo.
The US Postal Service leases space on about
15,000 of the 25,000 or so passenger flights
scheduled each day.
And some flights can even be configured such
that half the cabin compartment holds people
and the other half cargo.
But there are planes built specifically for
cargo, largely to support the increasing demand
for worldwide shipping.
Some basic models come from the factory ready
to haul as much as five semi truck’s worth
of cargo.
There are some interesting specializations
out there.
The door on cargo planes, for example.
Most, have the traditional cargo doors that
we see on passenger jets though cut into different
parts of the plane for the sake of cargo loading,
but for bigger loads there are special doors.
Like freighter-planes that open at the nose,
allowing the plane to take cargo like cars
Or like the Boeing DreamLifter, of which there
are only four, that opens at the tail allowing
it to carry fuselage sections for smaller
airplanes.
Airplanes hauling airplanes.
That’s so cool.
Another thing you might notices are propellers.
Most modern cargo planes are jet powered like
passenger planes, but a few are turbo-prop-driven.
Prop planes have more propulsive energy, and
are more fuel efficient which, again, is great
for hauling cargo.
But at the end of the day, regardless of whether
a plane is flying you or a rocket stage across
the country, it still flies the same way.
For more epic stories of innovation that shaped our future, check out TheAgeOfAerospace.com
Want more science every day?
Subscribe to Seeker so you never miss an episode.
Next time you’re on a flight look at the
wings, they shake sometimes, right?
Why don’t they fall off?
Trace can tell you here.
One super cool prop cargo plane is NASA’s
Super Guppy, made of a modified fuselage of
a Boeing C-97 Stratofreighter.
It carries spacecraft and rocket segments
around the country.